hey welcome to a new project camp update
so we bought this big piece of land and
our prototyping a more sustainable way
of living not sure how it's gonna go
let's see
and in the previous video you could see
us doing a lot of practical things like
installing electricity or the shower
with water and in today's video we're
going to make something less practical
something that maybe doesn't really make
that much sense to make at this point
but also seems kind of crucial in this
place where it's very raw in the evening
we don't really have something to do not
really a social place yeah something
that would give us some fun in evenings
so today we're gonna build
[Music]
so the pizza oven is gonna be made from
clay and this sand right here
and for this project we have malta from
germany coming to help us out and he
made several pizza ovens like this
before so it should be easy however we
do have some new twist to it this time
which is we want to make sure we can
still move it around because we're not
100 sure yet what is there going to be
the final location of this pizza oven so
we're going to build it on a metal frame
so we can lift it up later all right so
it's time to start building and the
first step we're going to do is to make
sure we have the right mixture of clay i
did some
sample
mixtures with the clay and the sand
to get the proportions right because
it's important to have the right ratio
between clay and sand so we always want
to have one part of pure clay and two
parts of sand
and
because the the clay is always different
and you have different particle sizes of
the sand
that you have available on site
you do some different ratios and test
out how do they behave when they dry
so that's the reason i did the sample
with no sand i did a sample with one to
one
and the optimal ratio
that you're always aiming for is two
parts of sand and one part of clay
[Music]
so
[Music]
uh yeah so this is the second step once
we got the clay um
we started mixing it together with the
sand and the right ratio
and the mixed clay we turn a part of it
in tiles now the tiles will be used
for the
inside part of the oven
and
yeah we make them ourselves so we will
produce
roughly about three to four hundred
pieces maybe a little bit more than we
need
you can
you can also make them round shape
i did that with the last 15 ovens and it
looks cool but this time we try it in a
rectangular shape because it will have a
nice effect
in the interior room
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so we're making a frame for the pizza
oven and we're making it out of metal so
that we can easily move it around if we
need it
and yeah
and we're making it so it's very strong
[Music]
[Music]
okay so now the frame is welded now we
have the legs so we can start to
reinforce it we're gonna add some beans
here also some here to be able to
hold the wood
that then all the clay is gonna rest on
it and yeah that's kind of the work for
today reinforcing the frame
[Music]
this is the frame
this is the pizza oven it still doesn't
look like a pizza oven but it is
the welding is done the grinding is done
it's we made it in this way so we can
transport it
we put these edges to hold the wood and
the clay afterwards here's going to be a
thick layer of clay to insulate the
oven
we make this
nice way to open it's going to be our
door
the pizza
cook it close wait
yeah no more noise today so today uh we
decided uh to pick this location
and what we want to do is we are
leveling the ground and we prepare
uh some outposts in the ground to have a
level and stable
platform for
the metal
construction to stand on
the side is
fantastic here it's pretty nice
[Music]
oh
measuring eh yeah
yeah
so uh we moved the structure to the
final location and
we secured some stones at out as
outposts so the whole structure would be
lifted a little bit from the ground and
be protected from
water
and
now we
build
the wooden
surface on the structure itself to
support the clay
and once we're done with that
we'll start building
a thick layer of clay insulation and
then the oven itself
[Music]
i can do
whoa
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
we just leveled the whole
oven
tile surface here
and um
we put some
clay in the
spaces in between and cleaned everything
off
and uh now we are creating an even
leveled
surface around the whole area
to carry the tiles that we made before
and the next step actually is to create
a sand mold so we
use wet sand to create a negative mold
on top of this
[Music]
[Music]
we have our
tiles that we made before and that are
sun dried they change the color
to have them
as a layer around this
sand shape
but
in order to avoid the sand sticking on
the tiles
we'll cover the whole negative mold with
newspaper
[Music]
because
[Music]
so
all right
[Music]
so
[Music]
is
[Music]
all right so we're still uh working on
layer a
which is
the bricks
that we
[Applause]
layer in here according to our pattern
and because
three people are enough to work on this
layer and with two more people that want
to
participate they already start with
layer b which is the mix of straw and
clay
and to apply that they
take a handful of it
and start positioning it on the outside
of layer 8.
okay
so that evening we kept on working until
we run out of clay good moment to take a
rest and go to sleep
so the first thing in the morning makes
new
using some advanced tools and some more
simple techniques
[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
the next and final step is that we open
the oven door
and take out the negative sand mold
and we will celebrate that together
because we're all very keen to see the
pattern of the interior
everyone ready
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
chili is like a shovel
[Laughter]
the oven is now finally drying uh it
took a bit longer because it has been
raining quite a lot
but now it's the perfect stage to lit a
fire we will start with a small fire and
ideally it will last 24 hours fire and
increasingly so we make sure it's fully
fully dried inside
fire time
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
is it now 3am dave you're still in the
fire no but it's later
fire's still going on we're making some
chestnuts as well
it's getting
strong
so we have been heating up the oven for
a long time now now we are doing a last
boost of fire which became a bit too hot
so we are closing it again
and then the oven should be ready to
make pizza
are we too hot you mean the pipe is
glowing and there's fire out there
yes i would say quite too hot
and let's see if it's gonna survive
the oven is getting uh at the right
temperature
we have a shovel as a two to get the
pizzas out
and we're now making uh the first pizzas
we have a sourdough one and a normal
yeast
we're gonna make pizza fungi because
it's
just the best pizza
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
good
[Music]
is
that's not worth it
[Applause]
it's super super hot guys yeah
you should have learned from them
you cannot feel the taste taste the
taste
we are eating pizza at home
not from the supermarket
he's good julie
yes
alright so that was it we now have a
functional pizza oven that makes
delicious pizzas however it's not really
ready yet we still need to clean it up
connect the chimney we need to roof
above for the rain and then we can also
bake pizzas when it's actually raining
and also we have this wooden board that
we put there a bit as a placeholder
because we didn't find a good material
but this thing starts to bend a lot
because of the
moisture in the clay and also with the
fire and the heat this thing is probably
going to wear out yeah the wood is a bit
warped and worn out already
so we need to find a good material to
replace this one with
but that's all for another video so yeah
that was it if you like what we do make
sure to visit support.projectcom.com
thanks for watching see you in the next
video